Durante este debate que se extendió por
cerca de dos horas hubo más
coincidencias que diferencias entre los
candidatos que participaron coincidieron
en definir al gobierno de Nicolás maduro
como una dictadura coincidieron en que
no será fácil el camino unas elecciones
primarias y mucho menos unas elecciones
presidenciales libres y que el próximo
22 de octubre la oposición no se va a
limitar a elegir a un candidato sino un
líder y un liderazgo que sea capaz de
tomar decisiones en momentos más
difíciles que se avecinen sin embargo no
hay coincidencia En qué pasaría si el
que resultara electo estuviera
inhabilitado por la administración de
Nicolás maduro allí la postura de María
Corina Machado quien lidera las
encuestas es firme no va a ser el
gobierno de maduro quien elija a su
contrincante y se va a defender la
decisión de los venezolanos que
participan en las primarias coincide con
ella Andrés Velázquez sin embargo hay
otras propuestas y otros candidatos como
la de Freddy superlano que hay una lista
de Sucesores En caso de que el gobierno
inhabilite el candidato o resulta electo
quien ya esté inhabilitado el gran
ausente Durante este debate fue el
dirigente opositor Enrique capriles
quien dijo que no participaría porque no
era momento de profundizar las
diferencias entre los opositores sino de
unir esfuerzos para enfrentar las
amenazas de la administración de Nicolás
maduro recordemos que hay un recurso que
reposa en el tsj que podría impedir la
realización de las primarias opositores
el próximo 22 de octubre